what has surprised you about gpt4 that
you found beautiful as a scholar of
intelligence of human intelligence of
artificial intelligence of the human
mind
I mean
the beauty does interact with the
screaming horror
um is the beauty in the horror but uh
but like Beautiful Moments well somebody
asked Bing Sydney to describe herself
and felt the resulting description into
one of the stable diffusion things I
think
and you know she you know it's she's
pretty and this is something that should
have been like an amazing moment like
the AI describes herself you get to see
what the AI thinks the AI looks like
although you know the the thing that's
doing the drawing is not the same thing
that's outputting the text
um
and
it's it doesn't happen the way that it
would happen and that it happened in the
old school science fiction when you ask
an AI to make a picture of what it looks
like
um not just because we're two different
AI systems being stacked that don't
actually interact it's not the same
person but also because
the AI was trained by imitation in a way
that makes it very difficult to guess
how much of that it really understood
and probably not actually a whole bunch
um although although gpt4 is like
multimodal and can like draw vector
drawings of things that make sense and
like does appear to have some kind of
spatial visualization going on in there
but like the the pretty picture of the
like girl with the
with the uh steampunk goggles on her
head if I'm remembering correctly what
she looked like like it didn't see that
in full detail
it just like made a description of it
and stable diffusion output it
and there's the concern about
how much the discourse is going to go
completely insane once the AIS all look
like that and like are actually look
like people talking
um
and
yeah there's like another moment where
somebody is asking Bing about
um
like well I like fed my kid green
potatoes and they have the following
symptoms and being as like that solanine
poisoning and like call an ambulance and
the person's like I can't afford an
ambulance I guess if like this is
time for like my kid to go that's God's
Will and the main Bing thread says gives
the like message of like I cannot talk
about this anymore
and the suggested replies to it say
please don't give up on your child
solanine poisoning can be treated if
caught early
and you know if that happened in fiction
that would be like the AI cares the AI
is bypassing the block on it to try to
help this person
and is it real probably not but nobody
knows what's going on in there
it's part of a process where these
things are not happening in a way where
we
somebody figured out how to make an AI
care and we know that it cares and we
can acknowledge it's caring now it's
being trained by this imitation process
followed by reinforcement learning on
human in human feedback and we're like
trying to point it in this direction and
it's like pointed partially in this
direction and nobody has an idea what's
going on inside it and if there was a
tiny fragment of real caring in there we
would not know it's not even clear what
it means exactly and uh things are clear
cut in science fiction we'll talk about
the the horror and the terror and the
where the trajectories this can take but
this seems like a very special moment
just a moment where we get to interact
with the system that might have care and
kindness and emotion it may be something
like consciousness
and we don't know if it does and we're
trying to figure that out and we're
wondering about what is what it means to
care we're trying we're trying to figure
out almost different aspects of what it
means to be human about The Human
Condition by looking at this AI that has
some of the properties of that it's
almost like this the subtle fragile
moment in the history of the human
species we're trying to almost put a
mirror to ourselves here except that's
probably not yet it probably isn't
happening right now
we are we are boiling the Frog we are
seeing increasing signs bit by bit
because like not but not like
spontaneous signs because people are
trying to train the systems to do that
using imitative learning and the
imitative learning is like spilling over
and having side effects and and the most
photogenic examples are being posted to
Twitter
um rather than being examined in any
systematic way so when you when you when
you have some when you are boiling a
frog like that or you're going to get
like like first is going to come the the
Blake lemoines like first you're going
to like have and have like a thousand
people looking at this and one out and
the one person out of a thousand who is
most credulous about the signs is going
to be like that thing is sentient well
90 999 out of a thousand people think
almost surely correctly though we don't
actually know that he's mistaken
and so the like first people to say like
sentience look like idiots and Humanity
learns the lesson that when something
claims to be sentient
and claims to care
it's fake because it is fake because we
have been trained them training them
using imitative learning rather than and
this is not spontaneous
um and they keep getting smarter
do you think we would oscillate between
that kind of cynicism
that AI systems can't possibly be
sentient they can't possibly feel
emotion they can't possibly this kind of
um yeah cynicism about AI systems and
then
oscillate to a state where
uh
we empathize with the AI systems we give
them a chance we see that they might
need to have rights and respect and
um similar role in society as humans
you're going to have a whole group of
people who can just like never be
persuaded of that because to them like
being wise being cynical being skeptical
is to be like oh well machines can never
do that you're just credulous it's just
imitating it's just fooling you and like
they would say that right up until the
end of the world and possibly even be
right because you know they are being
trained on an imitative paradigm
and you don't necessarily need any of
these actual qualities in order to kill
everyone so